Bradley better get on board and
it’s gotta happen in the next
couple of days or we got some
hard decisions to make.
Hard for you at least.
We were looking
for a character who
would be able to banter with
Billy. In my head
the goal of those
characters they would
have these difficulties but they
would forge a relationship.
With Stella she'd need to be
as smart as her elders,
but with a very different
sensibility and when you meet
Greta you'd see she had all that.
I don’t take it lightly to be
able to have this opportunity
to show a young Asian American
woman in a position in power
It’s happening in life,
so we need to show it.
And to get to do it
with these people who I love
It’s incredible.
Well I wanna welcome back
Alex Levy
When we did that dinner
scene that was the
first time that all of us
had been together
since the pandemic began.
I missed the cast, I missed not
being able to see them,
so when I get to see their
faces it’s so nice.
To play the scene that is about
a reunification I found
very rewarding.
You think Trump is innocent?
That- that’s not the point, the
point is that it’s a charade
The way Yanko is
being judged for his
political ideas is
very illuminating.
Are we even allowed to have
conflicting opinions anymore?
One of the great things that
Kerry has done this season
highlight that as a society we
want to put people in boxes
How much will it cost for you to
get off my front step?
It's a complex set of
emotions when
you’re dealing with this
character who has done these
terrible things and then they
come back and you’re wondering,
am I being asked
to just hate this person,
am I being asked to feel for
them now?
And I think that is going to be
left up to the viewer.
I'm really sorry Daniel.
Apology not accepted.
I remember thinking "God, he
really was not hiding it --
at all."
That was one of the first
scenes where we are
reminded that everyone
in this environment is
really really ambitious.
Winning is a theme In
our storytelling.
Cory wants to win,
Mia wants to win.
They all want to win,
the journey is getting there.
(numerous) Cheers!